welcome to the across the spoilerverse
podcast I'm your host Greg Greg Alba is
my name now and I'm joined here by
someone else who has the same name Greg
Alba II it's my evil variant from across
the spoiliverse what we're going to talk
about today what's on the agenda well
man we got so much to talk about we got
box office bombs today Greg Alba number
one and we also got Legend of Zelda
movie up reportedly being in development
some DC announcements like Batman brave
in the bold Superman Legacy we got
Shenanigans to go through my friend
what's the first thing you want to talk
about man
um well it's been not really part of the
agenda but just something that I feel
like we have to talk about in general
about the channel so Jared's left
um we ended up get we've got no I can't
make a joke about getting rid of them
there but I don't want to make like the
situation uh the guys kind of basically
Jared's decided to take a step back um
which is totally understandable I mean
when I hired him it was just as I had
had my twins and I was kind of unsure
exactly what was happening and I I just
thought you know I need someone else on
board here because it's gonna I don't
know if I can do everything he's came on
he's I think he's done an absolutely
brilliant job with the channel um if he
watches Mario breakdown it's incredible
but you know it's very demanding
um and and one thing that I said to
Jared at the start was I don't want you
to drop all of your channels and what
you're doing as well because he's he's
got a really big Tick Tock following and
he's he runs his own YouTube channel and
I know sometimes when hosts get brought
on board that they're put under an
exclusive contract so it's like you have
you just work here
um this is your job whereas I didn't
really want to be like that um I wanted
to give the the guys you know say you
you work with us but you find a guy
often do your own thing if there's a
video that you want to make yourself on
your own channel that's when you do it
now Jared has I mean it didn't give me
the full reason and but I do kind of
feel like you know we were constantly
putting not like forcing things on him
but he has got a lot on his plate um
he's got a contract with Roku
um I know that and obviously he's
running his own stream he's running his
own YouTube channel as well yeah he's
streaming service behind me yeah yeah
he's that's how he got so many spoilers
but I don't know why is that streaming
service there but yeah so it got to a
point I think where he just kind of
reflected on everything and he put a
statement out on Twitter saying you know
he was just taking a step back for
personal and
um personal reasons basically and but
you could follow him on certain things
and I didn't want to pry too much I mean
like I said you know he he has worked
really hard for the channel um he's
helped me out a lot you know there's no
there's not any bad blood between us
um he's actually so so what we've done
is I've said to him look more than happy
to have you back whenever you want
um obviously I know you don't want to be
working at Kevin's spoilers full time
you've got your own stuff that you want
to be doing you don't want this
demanding three job thing that you've
got the moment which I I mean I
understand that as well
um because you know he's got a thing
with Roku he's got his own Tick Tock and
he's got a switch
looking at what we do is very demanding
all the time like that Mario video if
you watch it bloody hell it's absolutely
crazy and if you had to drop something
out of those three things I can totally
understand why I thought you know heavy
spoilers is a bit full-on I don't want
to do it anymore
um so what I've said to him is why don't
you just do some freelance stuff you
know if there's ever like there's two
films coming out in the same week coming
up and I spoke to him yesterday and was
saying look do you want to cover these
things
um yeah I'll cover one thing you cover
the other and then we'll work something
out uh so it just kind of keeps him
around it's not the the farewell we
haven't had them taken out into the
woods and murdered you know what I mean
for betraying all the secrets uh but
it's just kind of something he said he
needed to do you know so yeah but
honestly best of luck to the guy as well
I am really grateful for all the work
that he's put in so yeah not really a
beef thing but go check the guy's
Channel out on jbox Studios on YouTube
and Twitter and just give them some
support you know give him some kind
words and I know the the comments
sometimes got to him and unfortunately
like
the way he was talking about things
again I didn't want to pry to you much
but one of those things with YouTube is
it's very difficult to um be like oh
just ignore the comments because they
can sometimes get to you and I even went
to people at what culture and said look
I've brought a new host on board and
sometimes they get nasty comments is
there any way to avoid this is there
something I can set up to handle these
things and they just said unfortunately
that's just the way things play out and
you know I I really did I really do
believe in Jared I did I believe in him
for the channel
um but just looking at things you know
he didn't feel like it was right for us
and we're lucky that I've kind of hit a
point as well where it was the twins are
all settled now you know they're going
to Nursery or kindergarten as it's
called in the US so my day's not as
manic as it was I can go back to
treating this like a full-time job and
yeah just just keep pumping out mediocre
videos all the time and start a podcast
as well uh but yeah no no bad blood
there at least on my end I don't know if
he's been lagging me off and going
that guy who's complete [__] all the
time being a [__] but yeah wish him
all the best and thank him for the for
his service I'll call it because uh he's
helped us out a lot his Yellow Jackets
coverage as well was really good he's
done lots of lots of good things at the
channel you can catch his videos here at
real rejects so he's gonna be
kicking ass left and right with
reactions yeah
and you know what was a bit sad some of
the comments when I I wrote like I wrote
a pinned comment saying oh this is a
huge thank you to Jared and like for all
his work on the channel and some of the
comments were like I was just starting
to like Jared as well and I'm like you
son of a [__]
six months ago yeah but yeah like I said
we've kind of worked something out where
it is not fully gonna be gone
um if if I can get him involved in in
other ways then more than happy to have
him back and and just talking about
stuff but yeah farewell
goodbye rest in peace
lovely rip pull one out for the Fallen
Soldiers but yeah all the best I'm gonna
transition us now after that really sad
drama heavy story you just told us about
Jared unfortunately because there's
other drama we got to talk about today
Paul and that is movies continue to most
likely bomb at the box office big movie
I feel like that's the theme of the last
couple of years everything yeah
everything bombs and you know we've
heard the reports about Little Mermaid
that everyone in the world is racist and
especially China's that was crazy for
racist and that's why little mermaid is
bombing
um
no please that's like a racist thing to
say though because I was reading that
thinking that the headline is saying
China like Little Mermaid bombs in Korea
in China because of racists
is that not a bit racist saying that
they're racist that's the only reason
why because it's just a bunch of racists
over in Korea and China it is the way it
comes across who's that is that variety
who said that was a variety or Hollywood
Reporter one of those things yeah I
think it was Hollywood Reporter no we're
probably slandering a perfectly
upstanding Outlet right now but it was
one of those but yeah I was reading that
thinking that's a bit kind of you're
you're doing the exact same thing that
you're accusing them of doing yeah maybe
maybe people in if I was Chinese right
might not have grown up watching The
Little Mermaid but even if I did yeah
watching what I'm gonna call a pretty
clear corporate cash grab a live-action
remake of something from another country
in another language I'm not gonna be
like massively on board going to see you
know what I mean it's like if there was
some anime movie that was all in
Japanese big hit in Japan not really a
massive hit over here and they said
they're doing a live action remake of it
you know I might go see did Ghost in the
Shell do well over here fair enough it
had a Asian actress Scarlett Johansson
in it uh but yeah that I mean that
didn't do massive numbers either I don't
think you know that let's be honest
these live action remakes they're not
exactly the Pinnacle of filmmaking and
you shouldn't be guilt-tripping people
and calling them racists just because
you know they don't want to go see your
American westernized thing that probably
isn't as you know embedded in that
culture as you think it should be I
don't think
fairness I don't really keep up fully
with the rhetoric the cultural rhetoric
around it because I I remember that you
know the last thing that comes to mind
for me is when they had um John boyega
removed from posters who I believe was
that I know when that happened so yeah
that was maybe there is a cultural thing
that I I'm just not that endowed with to
really speak on uh but the the headline
of how it comes across I feel like
lately you know variety and Hollywood
Reporter they have been leaning a little
bit more drama heavy when it comes to
stuff yeah they're clicks more than
usual and yeah especially with a Little
Mermaid which you know again the after
the pandemic especially what Disney did
with their films a lot of us just kind
of go yeah let's just wait for it to
come out on stream we'll be out in like
40 days let's just wait you know like we
don't exactly eat diseases
yeah I think it's I mean obviously that
you know whenever something like this is
announced we're not downplaying that
there are racist people who will just
criticize it and come out and give a
backlash but also saying that you can't
you you know you can't expect
countries to have to go and see this
stuff just because it bombs there
doesn't mean you know that they're
racist yeah to me at least well as a
white man but yeah if you speak for it
yeah thanks guys officially the
spokesman well yeah yeah it's I think in
the states it's not like massively huge
out here either uh it's big it's better
here than it has been overseas
um I love that however it's still not
like this massive Sensation that they
were hoping it would be even out here in
the states uh so yeah yeah I'm not I
don't feel like it's solely it's a
factor though I mean there's definitely
I can't we know that camp exists like
we've seen all the time on the internet
and We Know It exists 100 yeah but it's
I don't think it's enough to make a
break a billion dollar movie you know
what I mean oh definitely I think either
way you know if you remove that cam
completely or if you say you added that
camp on I don't think it's massively
Shifting the box office numbers you know
to me I can totally see why little
mermaid a live action Disney remake
didn't do all that well now some have in
the past obviously but we are hitting a
point now where these live action
remakes are getting very very repetitive
and I'm starting to just become once
when they announce it I'm just like all
right here's another one they're just
kind of burning through their back
catalog scraping the barrel as much as
they can and yeah if the movie is good
I'm sure it is good but
you you can't expect people to go out in
droves to see The Little Mermaid because
there's always going to be people who
just aren't that interested maybe they
grew up with it but they're older now
they're not like us who collect hundreds
and thousands of Funko Pops they kept
their childhood in their childhood and
they're not as interested to go see
stuff yeah so we'll pull up we'll pull
up a review for it yeah very bad okay
we'll not pull up that one I'm only
kidding there but yeah that's you always
notice this with um
when films bomb they always kind of come
up with a reason for why stuff's not
doing well and uh yeah right on stream
I'm gonna hit streaming it'll be fine
and they really want Disney plus to
succeed but speaking of Disney we also
got ourselves Indiana Jones and the dial
of Destiny and I feel really sad for
this movie we talked about this yeah
when we launched this it was one of the
first things we talked about was the
terrible three weeks ago yeah back in
the day when we launched this but right
now it is over the five day holiday
opening weekend predicted to only make
60 to 70 million dollars and this movie
cost like so much more than that to be
able yeah that's really really not great
in a heavy competition season and I
don't feel the review you know I'm
constantly asking the question to myself
of does the general audiences who don't
follow movie news care what stuff like
rotten tomatoes has to say yeah because
I don't I don't think they do how I
think they I think it matters
some people can be affected by it but I
don't get the impression it's going to
have because it's a long movie too isn't
like two and a half hours I don't feel
it's gonna have a great word of mouth uh
just based off of the conversation but
when I go on Twitter there have been
people who have now seen screenings
postcans film festival and who are like
I don't know what these critics are
talking about this movie is actually a
lot of fun so maybe it'll go up uh but
right now the numbers are not looking
super exciting and and you know like I
like that I was looking forward to it
just because I like Indiana Jones but at
the same time it does look like you know
just typical Indiana it doesn't look
like they're doing anything that
different with with the franchise I love
Indiana Jones yeah I've got all the
movies multiple times but let's be
honest Crystal Skull kind of killed
everything talked about this on the
podcast
the the final Indiana Jones film for me
is always going to be the third one and
it has the perfect ending it's what is
the best Hollywood ending riding off
into the sunset that's what happens at
the end of that film boom perfect no
need to do anymore they brought it back
Crystal Skull terrible and now they're
expecting people almost is it it's going
to be over 10 years at least at this
point isn't it well yeah it was crystal
skull
sort of mid naughties um
but yeah like you're not gonna recapture
an audience with Crystal Skull so what's
going on 15 years yeah that's crazy and
and I remember us making old jokes about
Harrison Ford back then and being like
this old guys Indiana Jones
um so yeah it's not
what like I am excited to see it but I
can totally understand why people don't
and again it goes back to this thing of
you cannot expect people to just go and
see your movie you have to really sell
it really Market it and I don't think
they've done that very well that where
whether it's the you know the Rotten
Tomatoes score
that lukewarm Applause had cans that
only lasted five minutes which they made
a big deal out of and just the things in
general around the movie
um it's just not I can totally
understand why people aren't excited and
it's part of it have leaked and that
caused a lot of drama as well and yeah
it kind of feels like we had that
perfect Indiana Jones trilogy
in protest I almost feel like some
people are like I'm just not going to
watch it because I don't I don't like
Crystal Skull and I wish Disney would
stop just remaking stuff over and over
again and actually come up with some new
ideas some new because you can't keep
Wheeling out Harrison Ford every 15
years and being like yes sir he's back
you're gonna you're gonna love the guy
like I love the guy one of the coolest
guys ever but my kids didn't grow up
with that fair enough they're two years
old or something but they didn't grow up
with Harrison Ford so that they haven't
got that attachment now one of the
funniest things I read in the deadline
article unintentionally funny was them
saying that though it was though it
seemed bad the box office it was
actually the franchise's second highest
opening weekend prediction oh my God I'm
like yeah mate because most of the other
movies released in the 80s when 80
million dollars was like a massive
massive deal that was like Avengers end
game money yeah so yeah you can see how
that kind of trying to spin it and be
like well it's it's this franchise's
second best but if you adjust things for
inflation it's gonna get flattened um
and it's a shame because like I want did
this to do well not even just for the
whole Harrison Ford thing James man gold
as well uh yeah brilliant brilliant
director
but yeah what
okay is Kathleen Kennedy gonna get fired
over this Greg I
don't think we'll ever get rid of
Kathleen Kennedy Paul I feel like she's
around she is permanently until she's
dead
they'll find her way they'll find a way
to keep her she'll be herself into this
whole situation she's never getting oh
my God I would love that be the first
one somehow Kathleen returned yes
yeah
everything's a joke now uh speaking of
jokes we got uh The Flash
which is continuing to have
um an interest I'm I've seen it yeah
I've seen it um I thought it was a lot
of fun I definitely had flaws for me did
a whole review on it it was
I'm gonna see it again actually today uh
because we got a door too bragging about
it he's seen it twice before everyone
else goes on our debut podcast I wasn't
able to go so I wanted a Redemption for
myself now I'm going to two screenings
um yeah it was fun Ezra Miller I think
is great in the movie to to my surprise
I was like Ezra is pretty great in this
film uh wonky CGI like you've heard from
everyone although I'll say that it's not
as truly bothersome as when you just
watch a clip there's a bit of a it's
kind of like a a more hot I'm not I'm
not just being nice about it it because
the movie Just sets out to have fun you
could tell that's the overall intention
and vibe that it's easier to forgive the
wonky seed that's why I think a lot of
critics have been able to forgive the
CGI even though everyone has that
complaint is because the movie is just
genuinely setting out to have fun that
you can actually it's a weird experience
where you can look back past a lot of
the past TI because the film is just
wondering yeah but when you just release
clips online then it's like oh man this
movie's a disaster when you when you
just watch them isolated yeah uh but I
thought this movie would actually track
better and I too I I think maybe because
some people are feeling like it's not
super relevant maybe they just don't
care anymore because you know this the
is it is coming I don't know what the
conversation is for regular audiences I
have completely I am completely out of
tune with what general audiences think
and feel for this like outside of the
movie sphere that we populate I have no
idea why this is not tracking as well I
thought the trailers were great you
would think that Nostalgia for Michael
Keaton would probably work a little bit
of magic perhaps uh but seeing that it's
expected to not do great and I even
think in our movie sphere you know James
Gunn he was he was trying to make it
sound like it's really important like
like this yeah start real this is
actually the real start this is when the
reset happens I didn't really know that
feeling
um after watching the movie that this is
the the official restart that is going
to segue us into the DCU I I actually
didn't get that impression and I've
talked with others who didn't really
they feel that way
uh but needless to say I am a bit
surprised that it's tracking as low as
it is because
I mean the flash show regardless of how
much it went downhill with audiences
um
and this to me is like the Cinematic
version of it's a bit predictable the
movie especially if you've read
Flashpoint and if you've seen like some
seasons of The Flash it's a bit
predictable uh but to me this was like
oh the Cinematic version of what I've
seen on what CW tries to accomplish yeah
Oh I thought it would just go over a
little better
do you think people are just sick of the
Multiverse in general I mean what what
the weird thing about the flashes is
that this was the Multiverse movie that
was supposed to come out first
um but obviously you know delays
happened directors got fired
so on and so forth
but since then we've obviously had no
way home which was a massive Multiverse
movie uh big success bringing back all
the Spider-Man into the spider-verse
across the spider-verse Multiverse of
Madness everything everywhere all at
once there's been multiple Multiverse
movies at this point and a lot of the
same beats happen across those
Multiverse movies I'm talking about
alternate versions of characters that
turn out to be evil haven't seen the
flash yet so I don't know if that's the
case uh but I'm guessing something like
that will happen uh there's also don't
give it away Greg there's also other
thing you know there's you bringing back
actors from the past
um to play in Nostalgia it's obviously
happened in no way home Multiverse of
Madness like had Patrick Stewart in and
stuff Sharon Carter and so on
um are they just kind of well people you
know Multiverse movies are actually
getting very predictable and there's
something that shouldn't really be
predictable I mean maybe audiences are
getting to the point where it's like oh
another Multiverse movie like I I
haven't seen the flash as I've said but
I've heard there's lots of plot elements
in it that are actually very similar to
what happens in across the spider-verse
thematically at least and but there are
some key plot points that are in both
and with that releasing two weeks ago
doing it really well maybe people are
just kind of burned out on that I think
also it's kind of been over marketed
um and when you're constantly seeing TV
spots all the times trailers I just stop
watching them and it kind of kills the
hype for me because I'm no longer
excited about it like it's even starting
to happen with secret invasion they
obviously released that five minute clip
the other day
um didn't watch it because and then they
they've been dropping TV spots all the
time and it's kind of like I'm excited I
went from being oh I'm excited to see
what the next you know I can't wait to
see it to almost being like all right
well I I kind of can gauge what my
response to this is now because I've
seen so many of the scenes and how they
play out rather than how they're in a
trailer which is when they're a montage
I think when you view a scene isolated
on its own it's almost
you you grasp what the the show is and
or the film is and it kind of almost
kills the hype for you because you're
now well aware of what the tone is you
know well aware of how they're Hamming
things and I saw the Michael Keaton clip
the other week and with Barry sat
talking to Bruce in the kitchen where
he's got the the long hair and the beard
they released that online it's like a
two minute clip
um and I just turned it off halfway
through because I'm like this is kind of
killing my excitement because I'm seeing
everything here so I think over
marketing it as well
um obviously you've got all the
controversy with Ezra Miller personally
I don't really think that's gonna affect
the box office either way because
I don't think that it's I don't know I
don't my grandma doesn't know who Ezra
Miller is you know what I mean my people
who would go and see this film that from
the general audience I'm not sure that
that aware they've probably seen
headlines and stuff but they've not
really
delved into the the full thing like we
would have see when we see it popping up
on our timeline all the time
um so I don't think that would have
massively affected the box office I
think DC in general is kind of in a
weird place at the moment like I was not
expecting Shazam to bomb as hard as it
did and I feel like Aquaman 2 is gonna
not do very well either
and I think people are just kind of
they're a bit weird on the franchise at
the moment I mean I've said this to you
personally but the flash as a character
in the DC EU is coming off the back of
what was released theatrically which is
Justice League
a movie that wasn't that well received
you know he's a minor character in that
he's coming from basically a movie that
wasn't that well received in theaters
sure sure they had the Snyder cut but
he's coming from that and also a dead
universe that people aren't really sure
of that's all taking part in this thing
that you know they're not that invested
in because they haven't seen the last
couple of movies and yeah it's it's a
weird thing to kind of have an entire
film built around this character so I
can see why they've been pushing Michael
Keaton as hard as they have been but
is Michael Keaton as popular as Batman
you know we grew up with him obviously
we have an attachment too but again it
sees you're Wheeling out yeah your
grandpa's Heroes and making kids be like
you have to like this guy don't you you
do you bloody love him and say I haven't
seen you know Mike my Batman was
Christian Bale is what I imagine they're
saying so yeah it's I don't know if it's
we'll see how it goes but the tracking
isn't looking good and considering
everything that's happening
I don't know if DC's like in a really
good I think the DCU might even be
potentially Dead on Arrival when it when
it drops
um I mean I hope James Gunn works his
magic but
yeah it's it's in a weird place at the
moment you know I I think The Flash
movie though will have
surprisingly really good word of mouth I
I think I don't know the word surprising
is it I think though we'll have good
word of mouth because this movie is
genuinely so much fun that despite
whatever you know storytelling editing
CGI flaws that the movie has uh I think
that the film itself will have such a
good word of mouth that people will want
to go see this I mean I've talked with I
was actually at a barbecue the other day
I I like to hang oh yeah
who don't like you know do anything
YouTube or movie related I just you know
normal people and and someone did bring
up because everyone I'm the guy who
they're like so Greg what's coming out
you know what do you recommending since
you got the YouTube channel
and uh the flash came came up and like
they kind of they they just they still
like go to movies but I was talking with
these guys and they were so confused by
The Flash trailer they they were
actually like wait I'm confused I
thought Ben Affleck was the was Batman
now he's not bad yeah I thought Mike why
why is Michael Keaton is it's Michael
Keaton like it was it became such a
conversation where I was trying to
explain to them like what yeah what's
kind of happening and that was probably
the most telling part to me about what
how General audiences might be receiving
this because we did get Ben Affleck as
Batman and then we got this is a Batman
and now we have Michael Keaton returning
and I really don't know how exciting
that might be for General audiences
because I don't feel like some people
feel like yeah Michael Keenan's the one
I grew up with but he's not often Herald
at least in those conversations I run
into he's not often heralded as the one
who is the best one of them all and I
think a lot of that has to do with our
association now with actor you cast and
their physicality matching them like
there is this one scene in the movie
that I thought was funny without it
supposed to be funny and it's not really
a spoiler
it's aft post post a fight scene there's
a fight scene that Batman has that is
great it's a fantastic fight scene and a
lot of martial arts and stuff that was
not in the trailer a lot of martial arts
and my mind is going that's definitely a
stunt double there's like there's no way
in hell this is Michael Keaton doing
like hey this [__] this guy's so
freaking old there's no way this would
have happened and and then but but when
you watch like Christian Bale or Ben
Affleck you believe that could be them
underneath the suit and there's a moment
where you know Michael keatonin is like
stitching in his arm up after getting an
injury and he's just oh like Batman
Returns yeah and he's just so skinny
though look he's just kidding ass dude
whereas you know Ben affle whereas like
uh he when he's in the suit he's meant
to be looking all buff and and all that
and I started wondering if there might
be a subconscious association with
believability that might also be
applicable to kind of circle it back to
um why we might not be as excited for
Harrison Ford to be returning in the
role of Indiana Jones when after you've
seen you know Harrison Ford in uh the
force awakens or even Blade Runner 2049
when he's reprising roles you can see
like this guy kind of moves like like a
much older dude now like great for his
age but he's definitely an old guy now
and when you see Indiana Jones that's a
character who needs to be a lot more
physical and Hands-On more than Han Solo
more than whatever Deckard is in Blade
Runner and I wonder how much of that
messes with like I'm talking about like
on a subconscious level of our
believability and tangibility and the
excitement that we would have to seeing
these actors reprise their roles you
know what I mean yeah
yeah definitely
um I can totally see that killing the
illusion as well I mean Michael Keaton
was never the biggest guy anyway but you
were going from like Batman v Superman
where you have a scene of Ben Affleck
working out and he's absolutely he's
crazy I think they were talking about
how they CGI that or whatever but it
made you think he looks great but I I
would like to believe in my heart of
hearts that the guy got in that shape
yeah um
but yes I can I mean I can totally see
that and again we're kind of pushing on
onto our kids what we found like good
there's a great line in Fight Club about
how
the Boomers kind of just took their
childhood and then forced it onto the
90s guys and we're sort of doing the
same thing where we're taking our
childhood and being like come on kids
you have to like this otherwise you're
racist
um and it's kind of yeah it's kind of a
weird thing but I mean I think the flash
will do better than the predictions
again these are predictions we'll have
to they're not what the final box office
is gonna be they're just analysts who've
taken a look at things and these things
can be wrong across the spider-verse was
projected to do a lot lower than it did
I think Transformers rise of the beasts
as well was predicted to do pretty well
but it's completely smashed that box
office and Little Mermaid was expected
to do better and it's done worse so you
know they're not always right that
they're basically rough ballpark figures
judging by certain things that they take
into account but the flash I I think it
will have good word of mouth I mean
that's basically what the marketing of
the movie has been there's been so many
people coming out reacting on social
media going it's good Stephen King come
out gone it's good Tom Cruise apparently
going it's good and obviously they can't
use Ezra in the marketing so they've had
to get creative with it and it's kind of
weird to see the entire marketing is
built around people going it's actually
all right you know it's actually quite
good
marketing of the thing you're right Ezra
is is I mean at the time of us this
being uploaded the premiere would have
already happened did you hear about Ezra
is actually going to the premiere but
you can't do any interviews when at the
privilege it's a it's such a fine like
this movie has the weirdest marketing
because they are trying to promote it in
all fronts but I mean it makes sense
that they would have Ezra go there uh
but because it's like if Ezra's not
there then everyone's just going to talk
about uh Ezra Miller didn't attend the
premiere and then it looks bad so you
need Ezra to be there but then if as was
being interviewed everyone's going to
ask about the controversies you know and
and then even recently Michael Shannon
um has come out with I think I have the
quote right here somewhere
let's let's get the quote let's get the
quote I'm gonna pull it up Michael
Shannon throwing I know exactly what
you're talking about yeah and he was a
part of it that I was disappointed in it
was something really yeah yeah it was
like nothing in the movie it was it was
really uh it was it was disappointing to
to see how he wasn't used and then what
he came out and said was he expressed
his own dissatisfaction with zod's Arc
in the film he said I'm not going to lie
it wasn't quite satisfying for me as an
actor these Multiverse movies are like
somebody playing with action figures
it's like here's this person here's that
person and they're fighting it's not
quite the in-depth character study
situation that I honestly felt Man of
Steel was I mean this has some nice
things like as it was great and so you
know people will be excited to see it uh
actually quite good it was good it's a
good movie and Tom Cruise likes it how
about you got like Michael Shannon
before the movie's release being like
yeah it's not really satisfying even
though they've been putting me in all
the trailers like they're really pushing
me front and center
that might be another thing to it is a
fascinating we've been I think we've
spent so much time on it because we've
been trying to dissect why people aren't
excited for where it's like you know
Aquaman also came out of Justice League
and Justice League was not loved uh but
Aquaman was a huge hit but it felt so
different and distinct compared to
Justice League whereas flash seems to be
heavily reliant on like if you liked Man
of Steel watch this if you like Michael
Keaton watch it seems to be
relying on the past and it really feels
like if you don't have that big
reverancy for the past then you might
not care about this uh when really it's
not just a movie it is a lot of like
DC's Greatest Hits The Vibes it does
feel that way a lot of the time but in a
fun fan servicey way yet I'm starting to
understand why maybe it might not be
tracking as strong and yeah when your
actors are not really super excited
about I mean yeah if he's coming out and
I mean this this happened on Shazam as
well there was a lot of stuff where I
remember David Sandberg when they said
something he was like oh yeah kind of
expected this to be honest and this was
on like the second weekend when it was
clearly bombing
um and it is quite a weird thing I think
just DC in general is just such a
personally I don't think James Gunn
should have announced any of the
upcoming slate until after these movies
were done I really think there was no
need to play his hand and say that this
was all gonna be dead soon absolutely no
need to say that at all no need to get
rid of any of the actors
um just keep it to yourself we don't
need to know we can speculate all we
want but let these movies release and
then say what's happening especially
because Superman Legacy that's not
coming out for a good couple of years so
there was no need to come out and be
like uh those stupid movies are coming
make sure you go see them they're
actually quite good
um so yeah I think they just played the
entire thing wrong from the start and
there's so much instability with DC as
well one minute you know Michael
Keaton's gonna be the Nick Fury figure
of the DC EU going forward God I forgot
about that I mean
started putting together my breakdown on
the film
um as much as I can and just kind of
looking back over the past two years so
what I do when I do a breakdown I'll
like go and research exactly how the
movie was made and what's kind of built
up towards it and I totally forgot all
this stuff where Michael Keaton was like
marketed as the the Nick Fury thing
because we have to talk about there's a
certain thing that we won't spoil but
I've had it spoiled for me that happens
at the end of the movie and there was an
original ending that we have seen photos
from because they were shown in public
so I wanted to talk about what the new
thing is and what was happening
originally and that whole Nick Fury
thing and then of course Michael Keaton
was going to appear on Batgirl
um and he was gonna be the Batman who
brought everything together whilst
Robert Pattinson played the younger
version off in another universe so even
just stuff like that and then obviously
you have the Snyder coat where teams
like oh crap they're bringing Zach back
oh amazing and then they're like the
next day they're like actually that's a
cul-de-sac it's a cul-de-zack we're not
going anywhere with it but thanks for
all your money and then Black Adam post
credit scene getting Henry Cavill to
announce that he is back as Superman and
then the next week being like actually
I've been not getting brought forward
um just so it's so weird and none of
this stuff needed to be made public
until they were like three months away
from the release of Superman Legacy and
could mock it there now what you're
sitting on is so many movies that are
Dead on Arrival now obviously Aquaman 2
is going to be coming in December we've
still got Blue Beetle this year which
but I mean they're gonna have to do a
hell of a lot of marketing for that to
get it in the the general audience's
mind and yeah DC is just in such a weird
place and it's all because of
mismanagement the Batman 2 is going to
do well obviously Joker 2 is going to do
well but this you know even with that
though you're kind of pushing these
other movies that aren't connected to
anything and it's like these are the
films we should go see and there's a
weird thing where they don't know what
they're doing week to week like do I
have another 10 years in me Man of Steel
released 2013. it's been 10 years of
this mismanagement crap well I don't
know if I have another 10 years in me
which is what James Gunn has said that
his plan for the DCU is going to be it's
going to be another 10 years do I have
20 years in me all together from Man of
Steel to whatever's gonna end up you
know coming down the line well possibly
not and I don't think a lot of people do
well you brought up Superman Legacy and
then before recording you mentioned that
that there was casting information about
Superman Legacy I didn't hear any of
this yet casting yeah don't put custard
in my mouth good but we're still gonna
put it all over the SEO and be like a
casting announcement but yeah because an
announcement
exclamation question mark question mark
exclamation try to hide the question
mark so that way or not yeah
clickbaiting yeah
so click maybe
we're for me it has a question it's not
a statement yeah
but I remember yeah what did you hear
yeah so uh Daniel opk has put out a
scoop saying Superman Legacy can confirm
they are casting these members of The
Authority the doctor Jack Oxmoor and
engineer but Superman Legacy building up
the authority in Superman Legacy that's
yeah so that's what's what yeah that's
what's been one of the big stories this
week I say big I mean to us it was if
you ask your uncle he's probably got no
idea what's going on and he's probably
just kicking off at something else on
Twitter
um so yeah that the authority is going
to be seeded into Superman Legacy which
if you read the comics and you've seen
them go head to head it's good to start
there I think it is good to start with
the authority this early because we know
we're getting a movie and that they're a
niche set of characters so building them
up now I mean I I used to get the
authority Comics don't know what
happened to them and for the last month
I've been TR well maybe even longer the
last two months I've been trying to buy
the graphic novels for them and they're
out of stock all the time I've got them
in my wish list out of stock all the
time on Amazon or if they do come into
stock for like one day it's like 60 quid
or something and I'm not paying that so
yeah it's uh it's they've they've done
good at hyping them up at least much as
I've been riding on DC for killing the
hype The Authority they're doing a good
job and what you need to in case you
don't know they're basically the boys of
DC
though at the same time
yeah so you've got these kind of complex
characters you know for it's right of
James Gunn's Street basically I feel
like he should be directing that one and
then someone else should be doing Legacy
yeah Superman is a weird choice for him
I must admit I'm still ensuring exactly
on how he's gonna handle it uh I don't
want to go hashtag fire get James Gunn
because that seems to be trending every
day but wouldn't it be my first choice
to do a superman but we'll see the guy
the guy is a great director and a great
writer so I I can at least put my faith
in that well this with him doing Legacy
and then he has been hyping up the earth
and the authority is just not as well
known it is one of those groups that it
feels so so much like a James gun pick
you know like yeah Heroes and they're
morally gray they'd be perfect for James
Gunn so it could be my probably it's
probably gonna be R-rated their stand
alone but this would be him doing okay
I'm not just rebooting Superman I am now
showing my skill set to do Cinematic
Universe building something that Marvel
you know fluctuates with but has been
credited as being like the pioneers and
the ultimate maestros of having
orchestrated that which was Cinematic
Universe building within their movies
and this would be like I feel like
um Creature Commandos will be fun but I
don't know if that's going to be the one
where we're oh we're getting a tease for
the future of the universe through this
it's going to be so yeah just start with
that yeah it is at the same time you
know he has such a a love for animated
movies
um I mean he yeah the spider versus his
favorite comic book movie I wonder if he
was just doing that as a marketing Ploy
so people would be like hey looks into
the spider-verse so you know Richard
Commando is probably gonna be awesome uh
but I think for Superman Legacy the this
path is is going to be an interesting
one and because it doesn't sound like
the authority could very well be like an
antagonistic element in the film but are
they just gonna be a cameo like I wonder
if there's gonna be too much hype around
the authority being established here in
Superman Legacy when I've it's like
who's the main villain of this I've been
hearing rumors of Brainiac being in here
but everything's just a rumor at this
point but sometimes the most reliable
rumors are coming from the most reliable
scoopers so yeah if brainiacs in it
that'd be cool that'd be awesome
yeah James Gunn whatever you say we have
to be careful because whatever we say
James Gunn's gonna reply to exactly like
right below this tweet when I post this
episode out saying you're wrong you're a
friggin idiot and everyone will pilot us
and be like ah it took so much rubbish
they don't know anything so we're not
gonna say anything's confirmed we don't
know we don't know anything I don't even
know my own name firm question mark
exclamation mark exclamation that's how
we're gonna do put question marks at the
end yeah is China racist question mark
question mark
the is but for China yeah yeah running
right path here all right and then but
also not just Superman Legacy
um Batman brave in the Bold uh the main
rumor is that Andy muschietti
which I'm not gonna lie
I thought that seeing
this is gonna make it seem like I had a
big dislike for the way Batman was
handled which is not it's not true
um but this I thought that because I
heard the rumors of Andy muschietti
directing Brave in the Bold before
watching The Flash
and it seems likely that he would be the
one to do it so I so one thing my eye
was on the lookout for was let's see how
he handles Batman and I thought he did a
fine job it was fine for the movie it's
like it doesn't ultimately feel like
Michael Keenan's entirely necessary I
sort of felt like some of the Ben
Affleck stuff was weird like the
specifically him as Batman I thought was
weird his scene where he's just Bruce
Wayne that they put in the trailers
that's a good scene but his stuff as
Batman my biggest complaint about it was
that it lost all sense of physicality
and weight yeah just like no is that
from the trailers it's it's really
noticeable and then he's got this scene
of dialogue where they're like on a
freeway and it just it looks silly it
looks really cartoony and it takes away
a lot of the that that looming Menace
that Ben Affleck would bring to to the
performance it felt something like kind
of at a Justice League and at first I
was like is this because he's in the day
but then I remember that in Zack
Snyder's Justice League there are some
Daytime scenes with Ben Affleck Batman
and that does not feel goofy but it felt
goofy here he did a good job with
Michael Keaton but that was really
trying to you know uh Riff on what Tim
Burton had already done and then put him
in that lighting and Shadow so
is a good director and I'm sure he'd do
something different than the Flash The
Flash did not get me less excited to see
what he would do with brave in the Bold
but it definitely didn't get me more
excited to see what he would do for
brave in the Bold
um that's I mean he did it that's pretty
dark that's quite a dark movie it tends
to be dark stuff yeah and I I think
they've said Brave in the bold's gonna
be based off Graham Morrison's run which
is quite a colorful run I have Frank I
want to say Frank quietly did the oh I'm
I don't think he did you know I'm gonna
quickly Google it so I don't make myself
look stupid uh edit this out everyone
Batman Omniverse one which
so we'll uh we'll so yeah that is quite
a colorful run anyway uh it's
that was it it has to be a little bit
self-aware I mean you're bringing in
like a little kid who's gonna be robbing
like you gotta yeah you gotta have a
sense of fun and self-awareness it's got
to really distinguish itself from
Pattinson's Batman which will be very
dark and brooding and serious and then
to separate it within its own Universe
the main Canon timeline I think having
that one a little more fun makes sense
so yeah I'm I'm cool with this one being
more colorful and fun
yeah exactly
um but from what you've said about the
physicality I think that is kind of a
shame it was Chris Burnham sorry guys
I've let myself down was it crisp but it
probably wasn't you know making this
worse and worse people are screaming at
the the TV and the the haters
um sorry guys I'll apologize for that so
what happened so what I've seen from the
trailers is that it looks
like I don't know he's kind of bouncing
off cars and stuff
um and jumping around whereas when you
compare that to the
the warehouse warehouse scene from
Batman v Superman that felt very
physical yeah that that really did I
think it might have been Chris been in
my back baby I'm back
uh so yeah it's kind of
I mean and but just Batman in daylight
in general is is a bit weird to me but
you know I kind of feel like he's
someone who should come out at night if
you've seen from I basically think
Batman should be like the monsters from
from where he he's you know the they do
it great in the dark night where the
criminals are kind of moving around and
then they see this signal in the sky
it's the the same way that Matt Reeves
starts the Batman like you think how
good that opening scene at the start of
the Batman is when Bruce is kind of
talking about how they think he's hiding
in the shadows he is the Shadows that's
what I think Batman should be but I mean
Machinery getting this job as well also
likely means that he's not going to be
doing the flash too because
he'll be committed to this for for the
next couple of years and you know before
the lead up to the movie they're talking
about how
they would want Ezra back for the sequel
um but the fact that Annie machete is
going on to do Batman and Brave in the
bowl potentially like how can you have
him back
uh for that if I don't like that to me
it it's almost doesn't it kind of
contradicts itself because you're hiring
this guy to do Batman brave in the Bold
but we also want to do a flash sequel
it's weird to me you would kind of keep
the director on for for one of those
projects and work this sequels from
there so I don't really but in my heart
of hearts I do feel like they're gonna
let Ezra go but they're just gonna do it
in a way that
I don't know I mean I mean they they
probably are seeing what the audience
response is going to be but if the you
know if this movie bombs
um I think they are gonna put the blame
on Ezra for it
and yeah I think uh I just don't know
that though Warner Brothers are saying
like oh we haven't really discussed
what's happening with Ezra
with this much money involved well we're
looking at a 300 million dollar budget
here with that much money involved they
will have had conversations saying
probably at some point even saying is it
possible to reshoot the movie without
Ezra like those conversations will of
course come up we even talked about it
and we've got no stake in this film at
all so yeah
we will see what happens but the fact
that they'd even be asking those
questions shows to me that there's doubt
in the minds of them and
I mean we'll see we'll see what happens
we'll see what happens I would love it
to do well our channels always do better
when movies do well we're not hate
channels we don't get hate clicks a lot
of the time tends to be when a Show's
not doing well or a movie's not doing
well our videos don't do well so praying
that they do well but just gotta stay
realistic with this stuff as well guys
yeah yeah dislike button doesn't work
anymore either so
unlucky mate you could have told us how
you felt you sucker it works it works
Paul they just can't see how many
dislikes there are but we see them and I
always count them every time one by one
by what like and I try to find 500
dislikes now why yeah they can't even
see it they just did it for me just for
me just the dislikes evil it's like when
you're driving along and you stick your
fingers up under like the door you know
what I mean so the car next to you can't
see it but you're you're doing it yeah
it's basically that it's just an energy
you need to put out there but yeah we
got these dude we talk so much about do
you see today we gotta we gotta have a
little bit of a power cleanser with a
different IP I think it's genuinely
going through my mind now that I've made
too many jokes about people being
racists and that they're gonna get
cropped out of context and we're gonna
get canceled and people aren't going to
get the joke because I'll be honest my
sense of humor is very very difficult to
get some time sometimes I will just say
something really stupid it I don't mean
it guys I promise
just being careful ever derived more
traffic to this podcast Paul if yeah
will bring people here and then you'll
get Defenders that's the best part is
people that's the best bit yeah people
ultimately like yeah you didn't hear the
rest of the context and then to hear the
rest of the context I'll have to hear
the rest of the podcast and then we win
and those people will instruct
doctrinate themselves to me and will
purposely go out of their way to search
my name on Twitter every single day just
so they can argue with someone I love
those guys yeah you know I used to never
understand how people got in Cults like
when I heard about Jim Jones I used to
think like I just don't I can't get my
head around how someone would be that
obsessed with someone else that they'd
be willing to do something like that and
then I see what people are arguing about
on Twitter sometimes like they'll be the
most heinous thing revealed about
someone and there'll be people who jump
to their defense to defend them and it's
very strange you can just see like this
cult mentality being formed which I
can't wait to weaponize against people
who try and cancel me so try your bloody
best mate ready the Armada let's get it
going I'll be on that side with you yeah
oh but then I needed to have things
ready to go for when you really truly
get canceled and then I gotta speak out
against you yeah you'll be just hosting
the podcast by yourself yeah I'm gonna
call real spoilers I'm gonna bring it
back
that's why we're gonna get canceled I'll
bring those three other guys over here
I'll still put it on the heavy spoilers
Channel though I'll still keep it here
yeah
um but I wanted to talk briefly about
this Paul if that's okay as we're
closing this out uh this news excited me
and also got me a tad word but also
excited if they if they'd pull it off uh
The Legend of Zelda movie is in
development finally this has been the
most Champion thing I've heard for I'm
sure you have to for many many many many
many years because out of any Nintendo
property that I mean people have talked
about like Samus and Metroid Prime and
all that that I think out of any like
pure Nintendo property Legend of Zelda
is the one that has lent itself most to
having a proper cinematic adaptation and
yeah it's like it would be the same
people who did like the super not I
don't know if it's the same filmmaker is
probably not but the same studio uh who
did Super Mario Brothers movie uh my my
one concern is my literally my only
concern turn is that if they decide to
make it like a comedy or something like
that you know if they just try to make
it like silly and funny because Legend
and Zelda can pull off something it'd be
really cool if they did just some wild
swing instead of trying to be like we
gotta find a way to segue Legend of
Zelda to being part of our Cinematic
Universe so they can cross over if they
just did some like wild swing where they
made something truly awesome badass epic
um but the animated version of it like
their animated Lord of the Rings in a
way and that would be the dream scenario
and I feel that's what most people will
probably want like can you have humor
come from the characters sure uh but I
just don't want it to become like an
illumination film basically yeah I want
it to be a truly like art Epic film
especially after like getting a movie
like across the spider verse I think you
can pull it off so to me you want
basically
you want a Shadow of the Colossus movie
with link and zeldadoni badass that's
what I'm talking about man how cool
would that be come on that would be cool
yeah that's by Shadow of the Colossus I
mean that tone where it's everything
since yeah taken very seriously not just
memes and Easter eggs No No One's Gonna
Be
like sitting there I'm I'm not going to
be sitting there making an Easter egg
video on it I hope I'm sure there will
be Easter eggs but I don't want it to be
like the level of Mario where it's every
single frame is 40 different things I
think
hopefully they go in with the right tone
and that will kind of make or break the
film because it's not the same as making
the Mario movie to me they should be
handling it like that I want to see
Majora's Mask I want to see Gannon
honestly Ganondorf on a sea swords being
pulled out of stones and causing time
travel or Inez I think it was I'm
talking all that stuff I haven't played
any of the recent zeldas but I remember
the old days and 64 baby
get the guy playing the ocarina
or you still remember it yeah Navi Hey
listen this way yeah oh so good get here
on the big screen baby I'll be down I'll
be there day one baby let's go yeah um
how great would that be yeah it's the
dream scenario
Hey listen
yeah some Studios have done that though
and look look how it turned out is there
now well um but China's racist yeah
always so we'll chat will it do well in
China it's kind of the barometer is
China racist about link can I see it's
uh like they go from week to week being
like Oh come on guys I think we need to
tone the racism down a bit over here we
better go see The Little Mermaid 2 this
week to me they're on to us they're over
in America
social experiment to see if China's
realized we just need to determine look
oh do we just do we have to be over
threatened by China's racism or not I
we're gonna get yeah we're gonna get
suspected to be like Chinese plants now
um trying to promote the great communist
state
um so yeah I think it'll be good I mean
it's but I do worry with this as well
that because one's done well that
they're now gonna just start green
lighting every single Nintendo and I
feel like they're gonna take the wrong
one balls yeah
yeah every single yeah but it would be
cool if they did get to like some Super
Smash Brothers I feel like the ncu is
something they totally could be pulled
off from years ago that's something that
we've all just there's several different
ways they could you know have them
ultimately Collide in some way
um and I think Mario builds that up
pretty well uh but it would be cool if
we got I mean even like Samus for
Metroid Prime like how cool yeah
there's they they have something gold on
the right I just don't want them all to
be funny I like yeah if I want to just
don't make it like like if you do Donkey
Kong yeah carry over what you did with
Super Mario that makes sense to me
um but I'm not gonna say don't make it
all animated because I do like animation
but what I would say is you know change
the kind of style of animation of stuff
love death and robots there's some great
almost photo realistic episodes in there
and I think a Metroid
set to look like that would be
incredible you can kind of look at the
cutscenes for these games and that
almost gives you the style of what to go
with yeah I think Mario works well as
the sort of Pixar Animation thing
definitely um but yeah I think you know
look at the cutscenes from Metroid
they're quite photo realistic uh so yeah
do that you [__] well that's all we
got on on the on the agenda today Paul
do you have anything else you want to
close us out
no go go watch the Terminator breakdown
I just did that's doing quite well very
surprised actually it's a great
breakdown they're bloody vest it's
bloody best it's a great one uh so yeah
go check that out please and we've got
the flash breakdown coming out this week
be talking about that talking about what
happened with Michael Keaton originally
which we've already talked about on this
uh black Camaro we're going to try and
do extraction too gonna be talking about
it all it's gonna be a busy week for us
guys what about you Greg baby uh well
baby Paul my week is this same coverage
as yours and I I feel like uh competing
with each other uh no I mean we're very
different you know people want to see me
be like oh my God this Black Mirror
episode's creeping this is how crazy it
is and I gotta do like five videos I'm
assuming your Black Mirror video is
going to be all five episodes right like
I gotta do five separate
no I might be doing five separate videos
and just drag it out until secret
Invasion smart not in a day yeah no I
mean just do like yeah post One A Day
damn that's crazy extraction two I'm
really excited for I feel like that was
made for channels like mine
to just talk about I I love my favorite
part of the review parts of it but there
are what there are certain parts and I'm
like yeah here's like a 16 minute winner
in that movie and I go that's what
reactions were made for right here yeah
I love Juanes I know yeah oh as gimmicky
as they are I'm a sucker for them they
they sometimes they are super gimmicky
but it says I'm like look it it's cool
it's all one shot even if yeah grabs
your attention yeah keeps you engaged as
well you feel like you're in the scene
it's very immersive yeah I love them and
for a 16 minute one it's gonna be
probably be exhausted by the end of it
you'll probably feel like you've had the
crap beat now Daredevil that that prison
escape Warner they did in that yeah
absolutely brilliant and by the end of
it I was like
I feel like I've just had their crap
kicked out of me yeah so I love uh yeah
I feel like it makes you
go through the experience yourself it's
it's sort of like playing a video game
in that you kind of you're you feel like
you're in it and you know if you manage
to do something it feels like an
achievement so I love them
yeah 1917 brilliant there's bits where
he's running in that and you're kind of
like just keep running mate keep because
it because without being one shot as
well you kind of feel like it's almost
like life like you're a part of it and
if he dies in the film it's like oh crap
I'm gonna die in real life as well yeah
but he just managed to make it out
Guardians of the Galaxy 3 does an
amazing one
um Children of Men was when I really
started paying attention to them they do
some incredible ones in that uh yeah
there's loads of great movies
1917 yeah there's a lot of great ones
yeah
some moves here to break down some
classic movie breakdowns okay I'm good
for today hey look Paul we did it we're
just a tad over an hour we did it first
time we're making I just noticed how how
shiny my face looks as well I promise
it's not this shiny in real life you
know guys every episode I come in I look
really shiny it's because I'm wearing
suntan lotion yeah because and then the
first episode people are talking about
my sunburn and then I've so I've started
putting suntan lotion on but now it just
makes my skin look really really shiny
so apologies again guys hopefully you're
listening to it audio uh yeah so thanks
a lot for checking us out you can
subscribe to us on YouTube you can
subscribe to us on Apple podcast Spotify
Amazon music Across the spoilerverse
podcast and we love you guys and thank
you for all your support We Made It
episode three so we'll be back next week
we'll leave you on that cliffhanger
goodbye bye